the burning of the Library of Alexandria
certainly ranks among the worst crimes
ever committed against humanity and it
is widely believed that the losses of
scientific research including that of
physics and medicine as well as the
losses of cultural and historical
knowledge and documentation setback the
progress of human civilization by at
least a thousand years now if you're not
familiar the Library of Alexandria was
located in Alexandria Egypt which was by
the way named after Alexander the Great
and is believed to have been burnt down
by Julius Caesar in the year 48 BC
however this is the subject of much
debate and I will get into that later in
this video
now the Library of Alexandria was more
than just a library it was a research
centre in fact you could even credit it
for being the first model essentially of
a university in fact it even had the
world's first medical school and it
existed for almost seven hundred years
prior to being burnt down so it makes
you stop and think if that was 2,000
years ago and we have so little
knowledge of it in so much mystery
surrounding it
what's historical documentation and
knowledge did they have at that point in
time dating back thousands of years so
like I said there's far more that we
don't know than we do know about it such
as was it multiple stories we think it
was right on the harbor however
according to ancient sources the Library
of Alexandria was described to have been
comprising of a collection of Scrolls
Greek columns a Rome for shared dining a
reading room meeting rooms Gardens
lecture halls and essentially like I
said the creation of the first model of
a university campus the library itself
is known to have had an acquisitions
Department and a cataloguing department
as well and we know that it had a hall
containing shelves of collections of
papyrus scrolls known as biblioteca and
according to popular description there
was an inscription above the shelves
that read quote the place of the cure of
the soul so how many Scrolls did they
have well the estimates vary nobody
actually knows for sure and nobody
actually knows what was in those scrolls
that burnt into ashes
however estimates conclude anywhere
between 400,000 to as much as seven
hundred thousand Scrolls
the only thing that actually exists
today is a basement what's called a
therapy M which is believed to have not
even been at the actual location of the
Library of Alexandria itself and you can
see the pictures of it here what's
beyond interesting about the Library of
Alexandria is the extent that they went
to gather information and historical and
cultural documentation from all over the
world and the library wanted everything
Babylonian text Hebrew Turkish anything
and everything was the goal in fact
ships that came to the harbor were
required to hand over books that they
had as well as documentation and
blueprints essentially of ships and any
other type of technology which originals
would be kept in the library and you had
professional scribes they would make a
copy of the exact original hands a copy
over to the owner and they did all this
for the purposes of prosperity however
nowadays is kind of funny that if this
happened nowadays I would be accusing
them of well big government but one can
only imagine what they had in there I
mean any source will agree that there
was probably at least five hundred
thousand Scrolls and like I said some
estimating as high as 700 thousand
Scrolls and by the way that reminds me
according to legend the earliest Greek
translation of the Old Testament was
written in the city of Alexandria which
many speculate well in okay maybe it was
written inside the Library of Alexandria
before I go into details of the
destruction of the library let me share
with you some of the people that either
studied there taught there or conducted
research there for example you have
Hipparchus an astronomer and the founder
of trigonometry who also discovered the
precession of the equinoxes and map star
constellations and was the first to
establish various brightness levels of
stars and then of course you had Euclid
the most famous teacher of mathematics
who was the founder of systemized
geometry and then you had the honestest
Thrax who defined various parts of
speech such as nouns verbs pronouns
prepositions and etc so I mentioned
earlier that there was also a medical
school established within the Library of
Alexandria which was the world's first
and it was established by her Ovilus who
is known as the father of anatomy who
identified that the brain was we're
thinking came from and not the heart
which was believed for thousands of
years but brilliant people that have
visited or taught or learned at the
Library of Alexandria doesn't
stop there take Archimedes for example
who's famous for saying Eureka I have
found it or that the shortest distance
between two points is a straight line
and also his famous quote about giving
me a lever long enough and a Falcom to
which to place it and I shall move the
world another person and you'll find
this really interesting is here on of
Alexandria who is a mathematician and it
was known and believed to have created
the very first working model of a steam
engine 2,000 years before James Watts
let me give you just one last example
which is really impressive Eratosthenes
who is the very first person to identify
that the earth rotated around the Sun
and he did so eighteen hundred years
before Copernicus and he was also the
very first person to find the
circumference of the earth and he
estimated it correctly to within two
hundred miles and by the way he did this
by observing shadows in Alexandria
compared to the south of Egypt at noon
on the very same day and calculating the
size of each shadow and that the
distance between the two ancient cities
all correlated and was able to identify
like I said the circumference of earth
within two hundred miles I mean isn't
that just insane and yet you probably
didn't even you never heard of that have
you I know I had until I started
researching this right and by the way
Eratosthenes also created the sieve
which is the famous model for quickly
identifying prime numbers these are just
a few examples and this is just what we
know of I mean one can only imagine who
else had visited the Library of
Alexandria whose works were just lost
into ashes so let me transition now into
the burning of the Library of Alexandria
now there are different theories on this
and it is a subject of much debate
however it is widely accepted and
honestly the timetable really
conclusively shows that it had to have
been Julius Caesar in the year 48 BC
that's not to say that there may have
not been more than one attacks such as
the aurelion and invasion in the 3rd
century AD or the decree of Coptic Pope
Theo Phyllis in the 391 ad and there's
even been suggestions of a Muslim
conquest in 66 42 AD or thereafter guys
that's all BS it was Julius Caesar it's
so obvious the timetable fits it
perfectly unless we forget this guy was
a conqueror the seizures that's what
they did they tried to conquer the whole
world and they took over as much of it
as they possibly good and anyone that
wasn't one of them was well referred to
as a barbarian for the
most part I mean look at this map and
this was taken at the height of the
Roman Empire which was just by the way
seventeen years
after Julius Caesar had died and I mean
do you think they took over all these
lands by I don't know just asking for it
I mean no they killed everyone they
conquered it and this is why many people
suggest that perhaps the Vatican
archives may have hidden knowledge about
what happened to the Library of
Alexandria or perhaps even ancient
scrolls or copies of ancient scrolls
that may have survived the fire
don't forget history has been written by
those who have conquered others right
the significance of the loss of the
Library of Alexandria cannot be
overstated
without a doubt it's set back human
civilization in the progress of it by at
least a thousand years and this reminds
me of a quote by Aristotle the fate of
Empires depends on the education of
youth and when you destroy information
when you destroy knowledge in historical
context and documentation it really
screws over humanity for not being able
to learn of the lessons of the past and
we're seeing this in modern times and
essentially that people kids what
they're learning in school think about
how much is omitted now I'm not going to
say that the Library of Alexandria is
omitted from school teachings I mean I I
don't remember being taught about it at
all at least not in depth whatsoever to
the things I shared with you today I
mean if I did learn about in school
because I can't say either way I don't
want to say they're not teaching it I
mean if there is though I mean what is
it like a sentence included in some
paragraph about Alexandria Egypt and how
they had a library that burnt down I
mean it seems that I mean ask how many
people you know who have ever heard of
Library of Alexandria I mean yeah most
people watching this video probably have
heard about it but I mean I guarantee if
you walk down the street and ask anyone
else ninety-nine out of a hundred people
won't even know what you're talking
about and that's part of the problem
guys anyways guys I'll leave it at that
I'm Jimmy this is bright insight like
and subscribe let me a comment let me
know what your thoughts are and sure any
information you may have on this topic
because it is beyond interesting anyways
guys I'll leave it there take care
everybody